26 avril 1986 une journée en enfer pour
les habitants de pripiat la ville la
plus proche de la catastrophe
située à 150 kilomètres au nord de kiev
une tragédie qui entraîne la diffusion
d'une gigantesque quantité de matières
radioactives dans l'atmosphère avec des
conséquences terribles pour les
populations avoisinantes et
l'environnement quatorze ans après
l'accident à la centrale nucléaire de
tchernobyl ferme définitivement ses
portes
mireille gorbatchev dirigeants
soviétiques de l'époque reviendra plus
tard sur les circonstances du désastre
la catastrophe de tchernobyl étaient
accidentels liés à une technologie
défaillantes et des erreurs humaines
les premiers rapports restaient prudents
et il a fallu attendre le lendemain le
27 avril pour apprendre qu'une explosion
avait frappé une centrale nucléaire
tuant au moins deux personnes et que des
éléments radioactifs avaient été
rejetées dans l'air la zone d'exclusion
de tchernobyl s'étend sur un rayon de 30
km autour de l'ancienne centrale
les cent vingt mille habitants qui
vivaient dans les communes du territoire
concernés n'ont jamais pu retourner chez
eux
devenue emblématique le site fascine
autant qu'il intrigue entre 2018 et 2019
près de deux cent mille visiteurs se
sont rendus à pripiat transformée en
ville fantôme depuis la catastrophe
un intérêt qui poussent désormais les
autorités ukrainiennes à vouloir
inscrire tchernobyl au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
c'est l'un des territoires les plus
emblématiques de l'ukraine
il faut le préserver pour l'humanité la
zone de tchernobyl et déjà une
attraction célèbre à travers le monde
malheureusement cet endroit n'a pas de
statut officiel l'ukraine s'apprête à
soumettre un dossier avant la fin du
mois de mars la décision finale de l'
agence de l'onu ne sera pas rendu avant